nowadays i spend my time mainly painting
i have an exhibition coming up generally
speaking i spend more time painting than
doing anything else except for writing i
I've been writing pieces for some some
pieces is connected with dld where I got
to me Frank Schumacher who's been
associated with the meeting for some
time and is an editor and publisher at
the Frankfurt or algar Manette side and
a remarkable guy so I agreed to write a
series of pieces for them and he's a
wonderful guy and I think Europe is
Europe is more interested in the in the
implications as opposed to the immediate
market meaning of Technology I mean I
don't think people are not better
educated or more thoughtful or anything
is different they just got a somewhat
different focus I think growing out of
the nature of the European market and
the origin of someone to the technology
in the United States gives them a one
degree of remove which i think is useful
there's a lot of thoughtful people over
there
well let's say this is the latest of a
series of exhibits a Yale which is a
good place for me to exhibit I like to
sell paintings not from galleries but in
a more informal one on one way and so to
a non-commercial gallery space in which
to exhibit is for me very useful I I
mainly I've been trying for many years I
guess i should say many decades at this
point to figure out what jewish art is
if there is such a thing it's come to
seem to me the jewish art is paintings
of words not just paintings in which
words appear or words on a wall but
paintings in which the words themselves
have have meaning and decorative
significance and a conceptual wait it's
a it's hard to it's hard to describe an
image especially one that isn't there's
somewhat idiosyncratic but anyway
general ideas
genetically to begin with what I do is
think of pictures I mean my own my own
job description is is an image thinker
as many people been and whatever I do as
a matter of the images that that float
through my head again they're there many
people think of images it's hard to say
how many certainly everybody thinks in
images some of the time many people
think in images is virtually all the
time when I'm when I'm working in
software I'm thinking of the picture
that needs to appear on the screen or
that needs to appear up here in the
users head in order to make sense of
software in us in the studio more
directly I try and take what as any
painter dozens any artist does tries to
take what is in his head and make it
concrete which is a constant well which
is a struggle which isn't easy but
that's what art has always been about I
when I write I tend to to write vividly
or to try to write vividly and it's also
a matter of the images of the drift
through one's head so this is the way I
deal with the world picture wise